it is testament to our commitment to
finding solutions it provides certainty
where breaks it creates uncertainty it
protects the rights of our citizens and
he protects peace and stability on the
island of Ireland
there will be no border on the island of
Ireland and the single market will be
protected the deal is not about us the
deal is about people and peace and I
look forward to continue my
conversations with Boris because we'd
start the negotiations on the future
relations immediately after the deal
will have been approved
we'll start our debates on the 1st of
November
without the interruption 2 nights
together we've finished our body I will
explain the deed to the heads of states
and government and of course it is for
both our Parliament's to have the final
say it's not only Westminster having to
approve the deal the deal being in fact
the treaty it's also up to the European
Parliament to do the same so Thank You
Boris for I have to say excellent
relations we had throughout the last
hoops thank you thank you very much
thank you John Claude and I pay
particular tribute to you jean-claude
and also of course to Michel Barnier and
all your team Michel in the negotiating
team in in the Commission and I do think
that this deal represents a very good
deal both for the EU and for the UK and
it's a reasonable fair outcome and
reflects the large amount of work that's
been undertaken by by both sides and I
agree very much jean-claude with what
you said about protecting the peace
process in the island of Ireland and in
Northern Ireland and of course for us in
the UK it means that
we can deliver a real brexit that
achieves our objectives and it means
that the UK leaves whole and entire on
October the 31st and it at first and it
means that Northern Ireland and every
other part of the UK can take part not
just in free trade deals offering our
tariffs exporting our goods around the
world but it also means that we can take
together as a single a United Kingdom
decisions about our future about our
laws borders our money and how we want
to run the UK and those decisions will
be taken in the UK by elected
representatives as the people of the UK
and I hope very much now speaking of
elected representatives that my fellow
MPs in in Westminster do now come
together to get brexit done to get this
excellent deal over the line and to
deliver brexit without any more delay so
that we can focus on the priorities of
the British people improving our health
service investing in 20,000 more police
lifting up the living wage and many many
other things and jean-claude I just want
to conclude by agreeing wholeheartedly
with your final point now is the moment
for us to get brexit done and then
together to work on building our future
partnership which I think can be
incredibly positive both for the UK and
for the EU and I just remind you of what
I always say that we are a
quintessential
European country solid European friends
neighbors and supporters and we look
forward to working with you in building
that partnership in the weeks and months
to come thank you all very much
I have job clothes the boss here yeah I
have I have to say that I'm happy about
the deal but I'm set about to exit have
a good time we heard just there from
jean-claude juncker the European
Commission President and British prime
minister Boris Johnson yong-chol Lucas
saying about this new deal that where
there was uncertainty there is now
certainty and Boris Johnson saying it is
a good deal for all reasonable and fair
let's go to Lawrence Lee now who joins
us live from Brussels just listening to
that Lars obviously a lot of optimism
but we've seen this type of deal before
and it has faltered where do things sit
right now in your assessment well I mean
clearly it does work for both sides and
that's the difference between this one
and the back stop because the back stop
was perfectly fine Teresa Mays deal for
the European Union but it was completely
unacceptable to large parts the
Conservative Party because they felt it
was a betrayal of grexit because he kept
the UK in an open-ended relationship
trade relationship with with the
European Union so it's it's good for the
European Union because it protects the
integrity of islands in the in the
sphere of the police because it because
it maintains the good friday agreements
and in the sphere of protecting this
single market because there's no customs
checks on the island of ireland equally
as you heard Boris Johnson say there in
his assessments it's good for the UK
because in one sense it does allow the
whole of the UK including Northern
Ireland to withdraw from the European
Union's trading arrangements because
there because there were the trade
borders as FX Goods in the middle of the
Irish Sea so both sides in that sense
can tick it off Janka made a big point
of saying he's not just westminster that
has to agree to this it's the European
Parliament's I don't suppose the
European Parliament is going to have a
particular issue with it the issue with
it plainly is
is going to be the UK Parliament which
seems to be able to have it in its will
to project every single deal offered to
it while agreeing to absolutely nothing
and it is perilously tight for Boris
Johnson the Democratic units are now in
Northern Ireland assets the crucial
points I think is going to be whether
the hardcore Exeter's in the
Conservative Party stay in line with the
Democratic Unionist and refuses which is
what they usually do or whether they
actually back down because they think
this could be the very last chance they
ever have to get a brexit deal done
because if it doesn't happen this time
there's every chance frankly if either
general election or even another
referendum which could overturn the
entire thing Lawrence I just want to
drill down a little bit more into the
Democratic unionists position and you've
talked there about this this compromise
around Ireland and maintaining the
integrity of Ireland in coming up with
this deal with Northern Ireland where it
remains part of UK customs but also is
aligned to EU procedures as well take us
to to the point of conjecture the issue
that the Democratic unionists have with
this compromise
the the really really impossible thing
for outsiders to understand about about
the Democratic Unionist Party in
Northern Ireland is that it cares far
less about about things to do with money
and trade than it does about about the
concepts of unionism the absolute
imperative from their points of view but
Northern Ireland remains a part of the
UK right it's a hundred years ago
yesterday that the UK started
partitioning Ireland putting the border
even between the north and the south and
the whole points of partition from the
UK side was to protect the Protestants
majority the unionist Protestant
majority of Northern Ireland and that's
what the DUP stands for any idea that
the Northern Irish economy could be more
aligned with that of the European Union
through the single market than the UK is
in their estimation an entire betrayal
of the idea of unionism because they
think it's a little tiny edge towards
the United Ireland which is which is
political death for them so they would
that the whole points of their existence
is to protect the idea of the Union and
if they say anything see anything
getting in the way of that they will
object to it on principle and and that
and that's what they're continuing to do
now and you know that ariza may paid
them off with over a million pounds to
support their governments and that
there's also talk about about about the
Horace Johnson's government trying to
pay them off as well I'm not entirely
convinced that it's about money for them
to be honest and just on that point
about the political negotiations where's
the negotiating room for Boris Johnson
here the Democratic Union is saying
that's it we opposed this outright is
there the potential for inducements
actually say as Teresa may was also able
to offer and then there are those who
are aligned within Boris Johnson's own
party aligned with the Democratic
Unionist are they going to stay strong
as well how does the the political
wrangling what does that look like from
now
but well I mean I mean you're talking
obviously about the situation inside the
Westminster Parliament if Boris Johnson
is going to get this deal through
because he's got a minority government
of minus 45 at the moment he's got to
gets the the Democratic Unionist Party
on side he's got to get both wings of
the Conservative Party on side that's
that that's the whole of the right-wing
hard brexit bloc and the 21 consider
moderate soft conservative MPs who reset
for not backing his deal they think this
is a much worse deal than serezha maze
he's gonna get all them to support it
and if he can't get all of them to
support he's got sand turns to labour
party MPs on the opposition benches and
say to them look how about you do this
because you represent people
constituencies who voted leave surely
this is a much better deal than no deal
so why don't you abacus as in instead so
it's perilously close on this and
there's certainly one estimation I've
seen of an intellectual mapping company
that says that he's going to lose by
about 17 or 18 votes on Saturday so
something's gonna shift between now and
if he's going to get this through